let's talk for a second about the
glorious the glorious epiphany of a kiss
to be kissed is to be touched her have
to be touched in the most erotic and
intimate of ways to be kissed is to be
probed to be kissed is to be tasted to
be kissed is to be licked to be devoured
to be sampled in body and mind to be
kissed is to be touched and deep in
intimate places and spaces to be kissed
is to be invited to be kissed is to
accept a dance surprise oh my god and
that feeling right when your lips meet
right those nerve endings come into this
this just dance this tangle it is kind
of orgasmic my gasping mind gas mix
space I mean that moment it's a neuro
storm right it's a moment of intense
intellectual pleasure it's a moment
filled with feelings of signification
and revelation like discovering
something for the first time right a
sense of first sight unencumbered by
knowingness and all of a sudden what
does that do well it feels you with hope
it fills you with bliss it fills you
with a kind of cosmic reassurance all
thoughts of death and anxiety dissipate
all sense of fear about the future
longing for the past also go away
time and space collapsed from underneath
your feet and you enter a holy radiance
right a holy moment what Otto rank
referred to as the mysterium tremendum
if a scene awesome otherwise known as
the numinous and this is a place you
enter this is a place you go right your
lips meet and you become something
together you enter into a kind of
heart-shaped myth out mythology and in
this halo there is so much to inspire us
think of all the pop songs think of all
the romantic comedies think of the fact
that you will never miss the opportunity
to believe in this kind of love and in
this kind of romance and man that's
that's why I love being kissed I mean
that's why we all love being kissed
that's what it feels like to be kissed
you